Anne hasn't walked in over 20 years
a condition which is yet to be properly
diagnosed means she's always in pain
cold and confined to her wheelchair
to retain heat you've got to generate it
and if you don't move then you don't
generate any warmth and says she's
limited to how often she can use her
support equipment as the running costs
are simply too high almost triple what
they used to be
every action becomes a transaction if
everything you do you you obsessively
look at the the smart meter to find out
how much it's going to cost you just end
up
with price tags or everything you do and
isn't alone National energy action
estimates the energy crisis has now
pushed more than 6.7 million UK
households into fuel poverty the Nea
predicts this number will rise further
in April to 8.4 million households when
the government's energy bills support
scheme comes to an end this is why
almost 100 Charities and organizations
have penned an open letter to the
chancellor calling for a social energy
tariff to help people like Anne who they
say are an increasingly desperate
situations
in April what's going to happen is that
the support the government's been giving
everybody but particularly vulnerable
households will end at the same at the
same time Energy prices will jump by
about 40 percent because government
would change the structure of the energy
price guarantee and the price Capital so
we have this situation where enable a
bad situation is going to get a whole
lot worse a government spokesperson told
Sky News that we know this is a
difficult time for families across the
country we are working with consumer
groups and Industry to assess the best
long-term approach to helping vulnerable
households from April
but for Sheila that's a long way away
184 pounds a week only stretches so far
so she's resorted to Growing her own
vegetables
and to stay warm daily runs with the dog
I don't use any central heating at all
because I simply can't afford it if I
was to use it I would not be able to eat
in a civilized country that should never
be allowed to happen
I mean older people are just we just
feel like we're just dispensable with
for now unless anything changes Sheila
says she'll keep running Summer chowdry
Sky News